now european union countries have
started to assess the post-brexited
trade deal reached with the uk on
christmas eve
the 2 000 page document still needs to
be accepted by the british and european
parliaments
the long-awaited agreement means that
trade across the english channels will
remain tariff-free
british prime minister boris johnson is
pleased with the deal but it might just
cause him a whole new set of headaches
the doors of the eu council close
britain has been estranged from the
block since january
and now the trade deal is finalizing the
divorce
eu ambassadors convened on christmas day
to signal the start of approving the
thousands of pages of fine print all
member countries
and britain are expected to ratify the
agreement
the eu's chief negotiator michel banier
expressed regret
saying there was no winner in brexit and
calling the separation a lose-lose
situation
while britain's prime minister boris
johnson made
merry exalting the agreement as his
christmas gift to the nation
because this is a deal a deal to give
certainty
to business and travelers and all
investors in our country
from the 1st of january a deal with our
friends
and partners in the eu the agreement may
have averted the economic chaos of a no
deal brexit
but commentators warn that britain may
have opened a pandora's box of troubles
not least scottish dissatisfaction
most of us in scotland would rather be
part of the european union than the
british union
i think well i'm thinking for myself but
there's a definite feeling that way i'm
fatigued because it's been going on for
so long
it's happening now the ball's rolling i
think we should just
finish it but i do appreciate that
people in scotland
on the whole actually wanted to stay in
eu personally
i would prefer scotland to be part of
europe
so that's the way i'm going to vote in
the future i'll vote for independence
and for scotland to be part of the
european union in future
[Music]
there are already calls for a second
independence referendum
to be held in scotland in the coming
year and
this is not the only unknown post-brexit
the uk will be in completely unchartered
territory
let's get more from dw correspondent
berget mass in london welcome berget
how is news of this deal being received
there
a big sigh of relief for many in the
country
many ordinary people are just happy that
they don't have to hear anything about
brexit
so much it was dominating the news and
it was polarizing the country really
quite torturous
over the last years for people of course
who voted remain
who didn't want to leave the eu it's
it's quite bittersweet um
they are not happy but the deal
prevented something worse you know like
where
chaos at the borders and and and also
more disagreements with the eu in the
future so
so even people who voted remain overall
relief that this um has happened
business as well
they are relieved that uh not tens of
thousands or maybe even hundreds of
thousands of jobs will be lost due to
no deal so you know most people are
happy
that that the deal is done and um that
that for now
it's it's quiet on the brexit front okay
um
deals of course require a compromise on
both sides uh who's feeling particularly
hard done by
well people of course students they
would have been not happy
uh that they are not part of the erasmus
program anymore
um and otherwise some people who are
very concerned about fishing so
brexiteers that
were really um fighting for more fishing
rights this is an area where the british
government had to compromise and they
started out
with a much bigger ask but um the bottom
line is that even
for even this deal allows british fishes
fishermen to to fish much more freely in
their own waters and
after five years transition um there
will be a renegotiation
so even on on that front um there is
there is some
uh you know some compromise um was
found of course you know the deal is is
something that
puts up trade barriers so the bottom
line is that um
britain economically was better off
within the european union and
brexit altogether knocks a few
percentages of the
the uk economy but without the deal that
would have been even worse
so britain leaves in less than a week
parliaments
in the uk and in europe will have to
sign off on this uh
deal will the house of commons go for it
well yes it's expected to be fairly
breezy this time not the uh torturous
scenes that we have seen when when
brexit
was debated in the house of commons and
voted on in the past years
the labor opposition party says even
though it's thin
it's the alternative would be no deal so
they are voting for it so yes it expects
it
to go through parliament without any
major difficulties
thank you for that berget massa in
london